hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge gold
simi later mir wurden wieder extrem
viele kommentare zugesendet was ich
alles machen kann ich habe mir davon
einiges durchgelesen vieles jedoch auch
ingo warum was bist du denn für ein
tollpatsch ich möchte heute zwei sachen
gerne testen und zwar brauchen wir für
beide sachen ingo flamingo erste sache
bin halte diesen paraglider davon und
zwar aber so was ist das da hinten alter
da ist doch nicht wirklich
das ist eine fucking rocket liga arena
freunde dafür war einfach ein paraglider
und daher fliegen und dann landet man
mitten in einer rocket league arena was
tut ihr da weiß nicht was ihr heute so
macht aber ich fliege hier um mit meinem
buggy den ich mitnehme diese scheiß
karre fährt die ganze irgendwohin und
manchmal will ich will einfach aber man
kann ich da nicht irgendwie einsteigen
ich will diese kabel rein
wie geht das kann ich eigentlich in
andere autos rein da in dieser map auch
einmal was ist jetzt wieder passiert ich
kann autofahren water for sogar die
ziege kann autofahren wieso habe ich
drei platz gebraucht um das irgendwie
herauszufinden dass ich wirklich mit
denen auch hier vielleicht kann ich doch
nicht so gut auto fahren wir haben hier
vorne sogar ein parcours den wir jetzt
einfach mal ein rallye-auto hier
gestiegen und weiß nicht ob ich jetzt
hier irgendwie ein rennen fahren
falls ja mach ich das echt nicht gut ich
hab nitro altersgemäß bay
viele teile zu steuern ist so fucking
schwierig nett ich habe ein ziel dieses
ziel wieder ein
jetzt wisst ihr was dieses auto auch
noch kann es kann springen
natürlich kann es das zweiter versuch
für dieses falsche taste gedrückt
diesmal schaffe ich es ganz bestimmt
mein gott die rampe
ich bin im verdammten gefängnis gelandet
da oben fliegt einfach so ein rocket
league autor um die leute einfach
polizisten überfahren der typ da oben
hat name beim cocktail wer bist du was
ich mir irgendwie besser slaughter fock
ich bin eine tasche ich habe mich
irgendwie wirklich in einer tasche
verwandelt ingo kennst mich doch ich bin
luca eine tasche in der tasche was kann
denn diese tasche überhaupt ist es
irgendwie was ist denn mein
grundsätzliches ziel für diese folge war
es ihnen wie dem paraglider zu töten
letztendlich haben wir rocket lied
gefunden in dem spiel und haben
herausgefunden dass sich autos fahren
kann und ich bin eine tasche geworden
diese tasche kann nicht ich kann nicht
mal so einen kleinen zaun irgendwie ich
beende an dieser stelle das klagt video
hell freunde hier nochmal ganz kurzer
nachtrag zum video es videos mit
dreieinhalb minuten echt arg kurz und
ich habe auch in letzter zeit immer
vermehrt kommentare gelesen von wegen
hey luca die videos werden irgendwie mal
kürzer letzter zeit ich mache youtube
ich hauptberuflich das heißt ich kann
nicht einfach aufstehen ich drei vier
stunden um ein video kümmern und dann
noch ein video machen und noch ein bier
machen wir schlafen gehen sondern ich
spüre derzeit ich mache derzeit noch ein
praktikum ich schlafe ich schon jede
nacht zu 45 stunden ich merke wie das
alles so ein bisschen auf meine
gesundheit schlägt mein puls ist
irgendwie höher und ich habe das ein
bisschen angst und keine ahnung deswegen
habe ich in letzter zeit versucht das
ganze ein bisschen mehr zu strukturieren
was überhaupt nicht geklappt hat
deswegen wurden die videos ein bisschen
kürzer hinzu kamen dass sich die in den
letzten drei tagen irgendwie pub auch
kräfte hatte und mir ist allgemein nicht
so gut ging und ich kann es
nachvollziehen dass ihr von mir von vor
ein zwei drei monaten diese noch so 67
minütigen videos geschnitten geschaut
habt und gefeiert haben jetzt sind die
halt meistens nur noch so vier bis fünf
minuten oder halt heute nur noch
dreieinhalb minuten lang das tut mir
einfach leid ich versuche dass in
nächster zeit wieder so ein bisschen
länger zu machen und ein bisschen wieder
auf schlaf zu verzichten ich glaube ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen regeneriert das
wollte ich euch nur ganz kurz sagen weil
ich da sehr viele nicht böse kommentare
gesehen aber so leute gesehen haben
geschrieben hey ich feiere echt voll
seine videos aber ich hätte gerne wieder
am tag irgendwie ein bisschen länger und
keine ahnung deswegen ich wollte euch
das mal ganz kurz erklären und morgen
wird länger